[Musique]
voilà
c'était un jour d'avril 1975 renault
fait irruption dans un hôtel et
l'animatrice danièle gilbert nous le
présente sur le plateau de son émission
midi première il est né il ya vingt ans
à paris c'est à gavroche vous n'avez
qu'à écouter l'accent regarder la case
crête et vous aurez tout de suite
compris il a également une politique
tout à fait particulière c'est la sienne
jugez plutôt d'après le titre de sa
chanson camarades bourgeois camarades
bourgeois issu de son premier album
amoureux de paname
camarade fils à papa tu as vraiment pas
l'air con quand tu sors le dimanche où
ton petit complet veston est ta chemise
blanche car toi regarde toi
le ton est donné renault n'aime pas les
bourgeois renault n'aime pas le pouvoir
ni les policiers comme il le chante dans
l'hexagone ici en 1982 sept ans après sa
sortie
ils sont pas l'eau en février à se
souvenir de sharon les matraqueurs
assermentés qui finit en l'air leur
besogne
la france est un pays l'afrique à tous
les coins de rue y en a 100 pour faire
régner l'ordre public les assassine
impunément
t
si avec ça
et parce qu'on fait niort en ce moment
renault séduit par sa voix éraillée ses
textes en train dargaud et son personnes
l'âge oscille entre titi parisien et
loubards quand j'ai fait une chanson
effectivement j'écris pour les loubards
pour les taulards les paumés des zonards
et déshéritées il se trouve que ça plaît
aussi à ceux qui ne sont pas de cette
catégorie
ça peut plaire aux bourgeois ça peut
plaire aux halles et ça peut plaire
aussi aux comptes venir et chansons des
positions bien campés dans les années 70
et 80 qui semble vaciller avec le temps
en 2016 renault surprend avec son
nouveau titre j'ai embrassé un flic
[Musique]
ça change des coûts de
deux heures d'avancé
et paraît la bonne
[Musique]
une chanson écrite après la
manifestation en soutien à charlie hebdo
au lendemain de l'attentât les victimes
des pères kwasi étaient ses amis parmi
toutes écrites qui me laisse porter trop
bonne tête et surprend chez monsieur
reprocher lui j'ai tapé sur l'épaule
dans l'ensemble je dis merci au frère
medhi serero potes c'est un bonheur
renault le rebelle s'est assagi il est
même institutionnalisée puisqu'il fait
l'objet d'une exposition à la
philharmonie de paris
[Musique]